من الناصره جاك خوري الكاتب المختص
بالشؤون الاسرائيليه طبعا لم يكن متوقعا
ان يتاخر رد الفصائل الفلسطينيه كل هذا
الوقت وربما قد يتاخر اكثر ما الذي يغيره
ذلك في الحسابات الاسرائيليه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني اعتقد انه في
الحسابات الاسرائيليه واضحا ان هنالك
سيكون رد ولكن بالنسبه لساعه الصفر اعتقد
هذا السؤال يعني لا يوجد اجابه عليه حتى
اللحظه ولكن هذا ايضا دعني اقول بشكل او
باخر يعطي نوع من الاستعدادات اللوجستيه
وكذلك على مستوى محاوله يعني ضخ المعلومه
الى الراي العام الاسرائيلي وتجهيز الراي
العام خاصه في منطقه غزه وفي غلافها بان
هنالك رد سياتي وبالتالي هذا يعني ما يؤكد
المعلومات التي ترد الينا ان الالاف من
المواطنين الاسرائيليين الذين يسكنون في
التجمعات السكانيه في غلاف غزه بداوا
يغادرون المنطقه هناك ويتوجهون الى فنادق
والى مراكز لاوايهم في وسط البلاد وفي
اماكن بعيده بمعنى انه لن تكون هنالك
مفاجاه من ناحيه ساعه الصفر وتوقيت القصف
الا اذا هذا تاخر بشكل كبير جدا يعني منذ
ساعات الصباح التعليمات بالنسبه للتجمعات
السكانيه للرؤساء السلطات المحليه ايضا
بالنسبه لجهاز التعليم بان يتعطل بشكل او
باخر هنالك العديد من الاجراءات الوقائيه
التي اتخذت وكما ذكرت عمليه اخلاء لالاف
المواطنين من خلال برنامج عمل واضح وموجود
لدى الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي
التاخر في هذه الحلقه نعم قد يكون يعني
مثير للقلق والتساؤلات ماذا بعد وكيف
سيكون شكل الرد الفلسطيني وباي حجم وايضا
ما هي المسافه حتى الان كل ما حدث في
الاشهر الاخيره حتى في السنوات الاخيره
بالاساس كان في غلاف غزه لربما وصل الى
مدينه عسقلان على ابعد حد ولكن هل سيكون
الرد الفلسطيني ابعد الى ما بعد ذلك ليصل
الى اطراف مدينه تل ابيب طبعا هذا السؤال
غير واضح في هذه المرحله هنالك ايضا من
يتحدث عن اتصالات حديثه تتم في الساعات
الاخيره حتى من خلال الوسيط المصري
والاممي وجهات عديده في محاوله لان يكون
محدود وبالتالي العوده الى السيناريو الذي
كان في الاسبوع الماضي ولكن لكل الاطراف
هنالك صوره واضحه ان الصور وصور الدم التي
خرجت من غزه ايضا صور الاطفال بمعنى ان
الاستهداف لم يكن فقط على المستوى العسكري
لقيادات عسكريه في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وانما وصل الى مدنيين وبالتالي هذا يلزم
الفصائل بالرد والسؤال طبعا الى اي مدى
اسرائيل على استعداد لامتصاص هذا الرد
بشكل او باخر وان لا يكون رد فعل على رد
فعل اضافي واذا دخلنا في هذه الدائره وهذا
يؤدي الى مزيد من الضحايا فعندها نحن امام
مشهد معقد ومركب وطبعا له حساباته ليس فقط
على مستوى اسرائيل وقطاع غزه وانما ما هو
ابعد من ذلك في ظل التحركات التي يشهده
تشهدها المنطقه بشكل عام كما نعرف الراي
العام الاسرائيلي والاعلام الاسرائيلي كيف
يتعامل مع هذه الصور صور الاطفال والنساء
الذين قتلتهم اسرائيل
يعني اعتقد ان الراي العامل غير منشغل
دعني اقول لك بهذا الموضوع قد تكون بعض
الاوساط المحسوبه على اليسارة والقوى
الديمقراطيه التي تحاول يعني ان تفعل هذا
الامر وتاتي بهذه الصور ولكن بالنسبه
للراي العامه الاسرائيلي بغالبيته بصلبه
يتعامل مع المشهد انه عمليه استهداف
لقيادات عسكريه نفذت اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
الاراضي الاسرائيليه خاصه في الاسابيع
الاخيره وايضا في الاسبوع الماضي وبالتالي
هذا التجاوب مع اليه الرد وضروره العوده
الى ميزان الرضع الذي تريد اسرائيل في
امام الفلسطين وتحديدا امام الفصائل في
قطاع غزه هنالك شعور دعني اقول ايضا في
الجولات الماضيه خاصه بعد الذي حدث في
شمال البلاد وبعد ذلك في غزه بمعنى ان
الرد الاسرائيلي كان محدود وبشكل كبير
وهذا الامر استغل بان هنالك زعزعه في
ميزان الردع بالنسبه لدوله تعتبر نفسها
دوله قويه وعظمى بالبعد العسكري والامن
والاستخباراتي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وبالتالي هذه العم تقرا اسرائيليا بانها
محاوله لتثبيت ميزان الردع اولا ثانيا
محاوله الفصل بين الفصائل في غزه بمعنى
هذا الاستهداف ياتي موجها بالاساس لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وليس لحركه حماس
باعتبارها صاحبه السلطه المباشره في قطاع
غزه وايضا ربما رسائل الى جهات عديده حتى
على مستوى المنطقه بانه هنالك عمليه
تعتبرها اسرائيل محدده قد تكون نوعيه ولكن
ليس بهدف الذهاب الى معركه شامله في
المقابل ايضا تقول اسرائيل لدينا القدرات
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه بشكل اساسي هذا
اليوم بشكل غير دعني اقول مالوف تاتي صور
من داخل غرفه العمليات في جهاز الامن
العام وكذلك في مقر وزاره الامن طبعا تظهر
بعض الصور المحدوده ولكن تقول ان مشاورات
على اعلى مستوى كانت لدى المؤسسه الامنيه
والتوصل الى معلومات دقيقه جدا تصل الى من
كان في بيته وفي عقل داره كما يقال
وبالتالي استهدافه بكم
كثير من الاسلحه والذخيره من خلال استخدام
عشرات الطائرات المقاتله والطائرات
المسيره بالاضافه الى متابعه ورصد دقيق
جدا بمعنى هنالك امكانيه للرصد والمتابعه
والعوده الى سياسه الاغتيالات التي
تعتبرها اسرائيل واحده من الاذرع المهمه
بالنسبه لها في مواجهه الفصائل في قطاع
غزه وبالتالي نحن امام مشهد معقد مركب
ولكن هناك اعتبارات كثيره تدخل على الخط
خاصه ما يحدث في غزه في الاشهر الاخيره
خروج العمال من القطاع الى اسرائيل هذا
عامل مهم كل مساله البضائع والحركه
التجاريه عامل مهم الحسابات الاقليميه
خاصه في ظل ما يحدث على مسرح الاحداث وانا
لا استبعد ان هنالك عوامل كثيره تدخل على
هذا الخط في هذه الجزئيه تحديدا وبالتالي
ان نتوقع كيف سيكون الرد والى اي مدى في
هذه المرحله اعتقد من السابق لاواني نحن
سنكون امام رد هذا واضح كل الاجهزه
الامنيه الايطاليه تتوقع هذا الامر ولكن
عمق هذا الرد حجم هذا الرد وكيف سيكون رد
الفعل مره اخرى اعت قد هو الذي سيحدد
المرحله القادمه كما نتابع